let's contrast the craziness of the view
and these people who are very upset that
there are people who actually care about
freedom and liberty in this country with
people who actually do care about
freedom and liberty in this country
here's ron desantis some of the people
in washington like can we actually agree
that women get pregnant and not men
because
because they don't seem to say that
i mean it's just it's just unbelievable
some of the stuff that you're hearing
about that
not to be a dick but women can get
pregnant and men can't
see what i did there not to be a dick
um yeah it's true and that is a a
statement that say i don't know four
years ago would not have been
controversial imagine i was thinking
about this this weekend actually
imagine just picture your grandma
picture your grandma and grandpa on
either side can you guys do it with me
in this room let's all picture our
grandparents now picture your
grandparents at say 30 years old and
imagine them being told at say 30 years
old that men can get pregnant
how do you think grandma would have
reacted back then how do you think
grandpa would react do you see this is
what the destruction of logic and
reality and everything else they would
have known it was [ __ ] they would
have gone to europe and fought a war
over it oh you telling me that dudes can
get pregnant we're going to normandy you
understand that's what they would have
done instead we sit here and take it
from these genderless queer whack jobs
that's what we do but we are fighting
back ron desantis is fighting back
that's why things are going so well here
uh and it's not just that he's fighting
back just against against the assault on
on biology uh he's also fighting back on
this lunacy being taught to our kids in
school i think parents in this country
should be able to have their kids go to
school watch cartoons just be kids
without having an agenda shoved down
their throat every minute
again just basic basic truth but you can
see it can't you see what the media is
going to do they're going to take all of
those things they're going to say he's
using that coded language of the culture
wars just like donald trump but he knows
what he's doing trump was an idiot trump
was orange and had crazy hair and was
tweeting all day long this guy might get
stuff done he's ten times worse than
trump
ridiculous nonsense